nbc reveals dirty little secret people
can't afford inflation just fine this is
a news buster story according to nbc
business correspondent stephanie rule on
sunday today the dirty little secret is
that american public can afford
inflation just fine and they're just uh
belating it uh belly a can get but you
just might have to sell your home or tap
your 401k to survive the winner and the
dirty little secret here while nobody
likes to pay more on average we have the
money to do so she declared for those
who own their homes and value their own
homes are up and while the stock market
isn't the economy you have over half of
american households with some
investments in the market and the market
has hit at record highs but those aren't
the most liquid of assets so is rules
advice for people to sell their homes
and take out a loan so they can afford
to eat what about the people who rent
what about those who rent and we're
relying on eviction moratorium can you
imagine the snobby message from this
stephanie rules saying look you can
afford it stop bitching that inflation
is affecting you here's what's so crazy
here's what's so crazy a guy said the
other day he says pat you have money why
are you complaining about gas prices i
said do you think gas prices affect me
personally no do you think inflation
affects me personally no matter of fact
do you think inflation has helped me or
hurt me helped you it's helped me
tremendously who do you think inflation
gas prices hurts the most low and middle
east lower middle income so the same the
5 000 jobs you made so the same with
your company so the same people the same
people who claim they care for the
little guy
the low-income middle-income families
are going up there saying stop
complaining you can afford inflation go
spend the money on gas and go shopping
do you realize the level of hypocrisy
when it comes down to the conversations
of inflation go ahead tom
so let's say this was
business roundtable
guest patrick bet david
conservative capitalist from florida
what was it you that just said the exact
same thing she said what would be the
reaction from bernie sanders all the way
down oh my goodness listen to this guy
he doesn't give a damn about the worker
it's a double standard this is
horrifying when i read this i was like
where is the outrage where is the
outrage if jeff bezos who's not
necessarily conservative came out and
said this oh there here it is this guy
you know serfs and lords here he is out
there just squeezing the little people
yet a a talking a liberal talking head
is allowed to say this never mind that
it's logically bankrupt that you'll
continue to sell all of your assets
until you're down to zero till you get
through a nuclear winner that you don't
know how long it's going to be i i the
double this this thing was just
horrifying to me it's a double standard
it's wrong-headed logic and if anybody
else said that they'd be crucified
anybody surprised though well no are you
surprised i'm not surprised i'm not
surprised but
you know i'm not surprised but i was i
was shocked in that i was not i was not
surprised but i was the same shocked got
it make sense go ahead tom well i don't
know if it's this chair this microphone
but i'm not as offended with her
statement as you guys are
i don't know if it's adam channeling me
through this microphone or whatnot you
know i will say this i am maybe not
quite as offended by the statement for
one reason she's a tv personality maybe
she look what she did i know her name
now i didn't know it before now i i
don't know if she was doing it for that
reason but i also will say this i think
everybody speaks from a level of
perspective and and pat i think her
perspective is i make a pretty damn good
salary as an nbc correspondent
it's not affecting me yet so i'm
speaking from that perspective i don't
know if this was an overarching
commentary of how it affects all of
america but just to take a little bit
different side here um i can see where
she's coming from a little bit because
but it hasn't hit her big yet because
right now prices across the board are
six percent higher than they were a year
ago and that number is going to go
higher and it's going to cross many many
more categories listen than it already
is it's it's interesting you're saying
that i remember running a sales office
and one day i look up i'm 25 26 years
old 95 of all my sales guys were under
the age of 25. okay uh they were all
hooking up with each other
i would come on sundays no joke on my
office and on sundays they're on the
floor having sex at my sales office
that's how crazy the sales office was
i'm not even i would tell them i'm like
listen go go to do from place and
they'll say look we don't have a
different place let's say dude i'm
finish up i'll come back in i'd give him
10 minutes i'll come back i'm telling
you the true story and then here's what
i realized these 20 year olds these 21
year olds were broke
they didn't have a market everybody else
they knew were going to clubs they were
rolling they were doing ecstasy they
were talking about what's the best g to
use and all this other crap and one day
i'm like i'm done don't give me a phone
number for another person that's 21
years old i only want to call clients or
people who are interested in doing
business that are above 25 years old
married with kids so watch what i did as
a single person sometimes when we talk
about kids what do single people
typically do i don't care why
i can't i don't think about what it is
to have kids right right but i realized
the reason why everybody in my office
was single
was because i only knew the life of a
person who was what single so i said
wait a minute if you want to truly be
able to get a clientele that's making
money that's married with kids you have
to understand what it is to be married
with kids and the pains that parents go
through right so this girl that's
talking about this inflation deal that
everybody else can go suck it up and do
whatever they're doing she's not putting
herself in the situation of a single
mother right now with two kids trying to
do her best to work in home school in
the state of california and trying to
make the whole thing happen and this kid
is having to go through this the last 18
months all she's thinking about is the
people she's around all the time so no i
don't understand her rhetoric that she's
got
she's living in a different world
completely out of that but that is the
whole thing like that that is the whole
thing about rich people that lost
perspective of what it was wants to be
low income in middle america if you
can't connect with them you lose train
social experiment they just go live on
their wage for a month and then complain
it's an insult if i'm somebody that's
making 28 bucks an hour and i'm trying
to do my best to support my husband my
wife my kids i'm offended by her
comments that's all it is i'm not
offended by it it doesn't do nothing to
me
zero i am not at all directly impacted
by this but i know tens of millions of
families who are and i think uh tom had
a great point in terms of if this was an
a person on the republican side or a
rich person god forbid that said
something like this then they'd be like
oh you're just saying it because you're
this or that they'd be totally railing
against it as opposed to just being oh
well i guess it is what it is yeah it's
listen when you lose perspective you no
longer connect with people bush senior
went through it where the lady asked him
asked him a question about the fact that
hey how does that affect you yeah and
then he gave an answer saying you don't
think it affects me and then clinton
came in and says let me tell you what we
do in the state of arkansas and he won
and he was right because bush lost
perspective on how to connect with
families that are struggling with this
the moment you can't do that you're
you're done with it but the ironic thing
about this is the audience for her is a
left-leaning i know voting and those are
the people that are suffering the most
right and they're the ones that are
least effect offended probably by this
because they're used to having this
rhetoric thrown at them the classic
limousine liberal so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]